(upbeat music)
- Money makes the world go round,
but managing it can make our head spin.
So here's some smart advice
from someone we love.
- Hi Drew, I'm Farnoosh and
here's today's Money Moment.
Saving money is important
ow more than ever,
and shoring up cash can be as simple
as making a few phone calls.
The trick is to be proactive.
The savings won't arrive on your doorstep.
You need to make the call.
For example, credit card companies
are reducing interest rates,
eliminating fees, and
allowing some customers
to defer monthly payments.
Just dial the 800 number
on the back of your card
and ask about any and all
types of financial relief.
Your cable company could
also drop your rate,
especially with so much
competition out there.
They don't want to lose your business.
Simply asking customer service,
"How can I save on my
cable bill this month?"
could lead to discounts and deals,
maybe even a free
month's worth of service.
Finally, if you're driving
your car less these days,
then you probably shouldn't
be paying the same
for car insurance.
And while some companies
are automatically reducing
bills for customers,
you may wanna call and confirm.
You could save as much as 15% a month.
- Gosh, that makes so much sense.
(upbeat music)